and last night the prime minister talked
to president van de leyen the president
of the european commission
and made clear that we need to have the
uh contracts that have been entered into
honoured properly and it was made clear
that that supply would not be
interrupted
so we can proceed with our plans and
make sure
that our so far highly successful
vaccination program
can continue but what about that point
specifically
why not start injecting those who've had
the first fisa jab
with the second one now there seems to
be some doubt about supply
we're confident uh we have assurances
that the supply that we have procured
the supply that we have paid for is
going to be delivered
that's why we are carrying on with our
program and i'm working with
ministers across the united kingdom in
order to make sure that we can
accelerate the rollout of that vaccine
program
to make sure that there are more jabs in
more arms exactly as we've planned
how do you see the government's
relationship now
with the european union going forward
has it been soured by this
well i think the european union
recognized that they made a mistake
in uh triggering article 16 uh which
would have meant the
the reimposition of a border uh on the
island of ireland
uh but now the european union have
stepped back and they've stepped back
following
uh uh clear conversations that the prime
minister
has had with the european commission
president and i've had with the european
commission vice president
they recognize that they have made a
mistake
and i believe that we can now
concentrate on making sure that our
vaccine program
is successful and also that we can
resolve the issues in northern ireland
that have been such
a concern to the people of northern
ireland you talk about the european
union making a mistake does the uk
feel it's got the upper hand now no we
want to work with our friends and
neighbours in the european union we
recognize some of the difficulties
and the pressures that they face but the
decision uh
yesterday to trigger article 16 uh to
you know in effect see the reimposition
of a border on the island of ireland
that was a mistake that's been
acknowledged now we can move on
and we can ensure that the issues which
the people of northern ireland
are legitimately concerned about can be
addressed
i've spoken to the european commission
vice president mauro chefkevich about
this
and we've both agreed that we need a
reset that we need to put the people of
northern ireland first
you talked about supply and you're
confident about supply
was the prime minister reassured when he
spoke to ursula vonderlein
about vaccine supplies did she give
assurances
about for example the demand to divert
astrozenica
vaccines to the european union the prime
minister was very clear
we've entered into contractual
arrangements with astra seneca and
pfizer
we expect those arrangements to be
honoured uh and president von der line
was clear that she
understood exactly the uk government's
position
so we expect that those contracts will
be honored we expect that vaccines will
continue to be supplied
the uk government's position is
absolutely clear we expect
companies and contracts to be honoured
um our european union know that and of
course
we'll work with them in order to make
sure that their own problems can be
tackled
because as i say our first priority is
vaccinating people in the united kingdom
but we also want to work with our
friends and neighbours in the european
union
in order to help them as well if you're
confident about supply then
um and no interruption um
how confident are you that um
how confident are you that the
government will meet the target
of 15 million vaccinations by the
middle of february the 15th of february
we're fully on course to meet the target
of uh 15 million vaccinations by the
middle of
february uh that means that the four
most vulnerable cohorts
will have been vaccinated and that we
will then go on to make sure
that the nine most vulnerable cohorts
which have been identified by the joint
committee on vaccination and inoculation
are also uh vaccinated as well it's
really important
that this program across the united
kingdom
is not interrupted it's vital to the
nation's health and to our prospects of
economic recovery
and under the leadership of uh matt
hancock and
kate bingham and the prime minister alok
sharma and quasi quarten
that campaign is succeeding um how
concerned are you about the european
using uh union union using article 16
which i think you'd probably agree is
due to it's supposed to be a last resort
isn't it
how concerned are you about them using
article 16 does this
lower the bar uh for using article 16
philip rycroft a former
civil servant from the uh brexit
department has suggested that it might
well i think the european union
recognized now that uh they made a
mistake yesterday the commission
made a mistake they didn't consult us
they didn't consult our friends in
dublin
um and they united parties in northern
ireland from shin fein on one side to
the dup
on the other in condemnation and people
in northern ireland were bewildered by
this step
now the commission has stepped back and
i've talked to the commission vice
president mao
shefkovich about this he recognizes he's
committed
to making sure that the the belfast
agreement works in the interests of all
of northern ireland's people and he
recognizes therefore that we do need a
reset
and i'm looking forward to working with
him and the parties in northern ireland
to help address the problems that people
in northern ireland have identified
what does this episode say about the
european union's attitude to brexit
are you one of those who says this shows
you we were right to leave
well i i've always argued that we were
right to sleep but i also think it's
important
that we have good relations with our
friends and neighbours
and that's why i wanted to make sure
that we can do everything we can
after the mistake that was made
yesterday to make sure that we can work
together ultimately it's in all of our
interests
to see companies honour their contracts
promises kept
the rule of law respected and friendship
and cooperation between nations advance
now britain as a sovereign nation is
playing its role once more
as a leader in standing up for those
values and we want to be alongside our
friends
and our neighbors in the european union
in pushing that agenda forward
do you think they've behaved and you
talked about a mistake do you think
they've behaved totally unreasonably
because they're annoyed that the uk
seems to be further ahead
ahead in terms of the timetable with
vaccinations
well when friends make mistakes uh the
most important thing to do
is to help everyone to get back onto the
right track so
yes a mistake was made yesterday but i
think it's also important that we
recognize
that while we must prioritize the
vaccination of british citizens
is also in our interest to support our
friends and neighbors with their vaccine
program
and we will do that consistent with
making sure
that contracts are honored promises are
kept and that uk citizens are vaccinated
first
what did you think of president macron's
claim that one of the vaccines
doesn't work for over 65s well when it
comes to looking at how effective
vaccines are i think all of us
will want to look at the scientific
evidence i'm confident on the basis of
what scientists in this country and
elsewhere have said
that our vaccination program is the
right program administered in the right
way for the right reasons
two days ago you said sir desmond swain
should apologize and retract his remarks
about vaccines and
perhaps suggested that some disciplinary
actions should be taken against him
that hasn't happened why has uh sir
desmond been led off with no action
being taken against him
watch this space ah what's going to
happen then
well i i can't preempt any decision
making but i think it's important that
uh
uh the processes that the conservative
party has are in place in order to make
sure
as i'm sure he will that sir desmond uh
apologizes
and recognizes that he made a mistake
when you say watch this space are you
expecting the chief whip to take some
action uh
i won't see any more than i've just said
you're a former chief whip
uh yes i am but as a result of that i
know that uh you leave these matters
to the appropriate people